[THEME MUSIC]
VICTOR TSARAN: Hello, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Hi!
VICTOR TSARAN: Fabulous.
My name is Victor Tsaran.
I'm an Android accessibility
technical program manager,
and we're super happy that you
decided to spend the next 40
minutes of your time
at this conference
with us learning about
accessibility and about
related work we do at Google.
So thank you for
that, and that's cool.
So why we're here today--
in this session, we
would like to showcase
how access to surrounding
environment, information,
and technology can empower
people with disabilities
to be productive and
independent in their lives.
According to World
Health Organization,
there's over one billion people
with disabilities in the world.
That's nine zeros.
150 million of these people
have difficulty performing even
the most basic of daily tasks.
For example, some of
us take for granted
picking up a glass of water,
or walking out of the house
to your favorite
restaurant, or listening
to a video on YouTube,
or finding something
in a low lighting conditions.
For other people, these tasks
aren't so easily achievable.
Technology has an amazing
power to change that.
In fact, if you think
about it, for millennia,
humanity has been developing
low and high tech gadgets.
I'll give you a few
examples-- wheel.
Sorry, no Nobel
Prize for this one,
but fire, clock,
typewriter, smartphone.
All of these things we have been
creating so that we can improve
the quality of our lives.
For some people, this
is just to improve
the quality of their lives.
Yet for others, like for
people with disabilities,
these gadgets, these new
technical advancements,
made it possible, in many cases,
enabled to live their lives.
I, for example, being
completely blind,
could not do my work at Google
without assistive technology
or computers or other tools that
help me to do very basic things
in my life--
paying bills, taxes,
what have you.
So in this case,
again, technology
is just super
important, and today, we
would like to talk to you
about some of that technology.
Now, some of you
probably in the audience
have experienced low
lighting conditions,
where you were trying
to find something,
or how about a
shaky train, where
you were trying
to read something,
the book that you'd
been waiting for so long
to pick up and read.
Many things, right?
You might remember
discomfort and frustration
that you find yourself grappling
with when finding yourself
in such circumstances.
You probably wouldn't want
discomfort and frustration
to be companion for
the rest of your life,
but unfortunately for many
people with disabilities,
it is.
They have to live with this.
Now, technology, as
I mentioned before,
has an amazing power
to change, if not
all of that, then certainly
a lot of these things.
We at Google actually create
some of that technology.
I think we know something
about technology at Google.
We create that
technology, and since we
create that technology,
we feel like we have you
here for that purpose,
so we can tell you
about things we create.
Over the last year,
we've been working
hard on creating
some of the new tools
to help people
with disabilities,
but also create new APIs and
frameworks to help developers
like you to create
more accessible apps
and more inclusive products.
With that, I would like to
invite Brian to talk to you,
to kick off our marathon
and to talk about--
well, where is Brian?
BRIAN KEMLER: I'm right here.
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh, you're here.
BRIAN KEMLER: I'm here.
VICTOR TSARAN: All right.
Here's-- here goes Brian.
Welcome, Brian.
BRIAN KEMLER: Thank you, Victor.
Thank you, everybody.
My name is Brian Kemler,
and I'm a product manager
on Android Accessibility.
I'm excited to discuss
our new accessibility
services and the APIs
that make them possible.
Now, let's dive
in and discuss how
we're innovating in this space.
First, I'm going to talk about
what we're doing in Android P
to make hearing conversations
a little easier.
Listening is difficult even in
a quiet field with no background
noise and a large set of
ears, but the everyday reality
is we live, work, and
play with an increasing
amount of environmental noise.
In fact, unwanted sound
is one of the most common
environmental problems.
It's not only annoying,
but it prevents us
from understanding our
colleagues, friends,
and loved ones.
No matter how well
we can hear, most of
us can relate to the following
acoustically challenging
situations--
listening to your dinner
date in a loud restaurant,
trying to listen to a caller
in a loud airport lounge,
listening to our presenter
who is speaking too softly,
like me right now.
One could think about
environmental noise
as a form of
situational disability,
but what if you could
turn down the noise
and boost the signal
on your smartphone
so you would never
miss the conversation?
Now you can, because today we're
introducing Sound Amplifier.
Sound Amplifier is a new
accessibility service
that helps users focus on
real world conversations using
only an Android smartphone
and a set of headphones.
Users can tune hundreds
of personalized levels
to optimize their
listening experience
to the current environment.
Its two sliders, for
loudness and tuning,
dynamically adjust
over 100 audio presets
in the background.
The settings can then
be independently applied
to each ear.
Adjusting them provides
ambient sound--
improves ambient sound quality
in a vast array of scenarios,
including enhancing sound in
loud, distant, or far away
spaces, increasing the volume
of somebody who speaks softly,
turning up the TV
to a volume that's
understandable and acceptable
for everybody in the room.
Now, I'm going to
briefly explain
how it was built using the new
dynamics processing effect.
Sound Amplifier was built on the
new dynamics processing effect
in Android's audio framework.
The effect is based on a
four-stage signal processing
architecture.
Stage one is pre-equalization.
You could think about
the pre-equalizer
as a programmatic way to
adjust any audio frequency.
Think bass to treble and
everything in between.
Stage two is a
multi-band compressor.
The multi-band compressor
is the keystone
of the dynamic
processing effect.
It adjusts soft sounds
and adjusts down loud
sounds to provide a much
better listening experience.
Stage three is
post-equalization.
Similar to the first stage,
it allows you to fine tune
any audio frequency.
Lastly, stage four, the limiter,
prevents additional gain
above a developer designated
threshold, which prevents
loud or unwanted noises.
We're going to be doing a
number of demos and a deep dive
on the dynamics processing
effect and Sound Amplifier
Thursday at 3:30 on Stage
5, so please join us there
if you want to learn more.
Switching topics,
I'm going to discuss
what we're doing to make Android
easier for users with mobility
and dexterity challenges.
For example, we're going to
do a little empathy exercise.
So first, I'm going
to ask everybody
to take out their phones.
All right, now, I want
everybody to take a screenshot.
This does have a purpose.
Take a screen shot, please.
After you've done that, I
want you to do it again,
but I want you to do
it with just one hand.
Screenshot-- screenshot
on your phone.
Not quite as easy,
is it, with one hand?
For tens of millions of users.
This is their everyday reality.
These might be users with
tremors or limited hand
strength.
For them, simple tasks,
such as holding the phone,
pressing hardware buttons,
or performing gestures,
can be difficult, painful,
and time consuming.
Accessibility service--
Accessibility Menu
is a new accessibility
service to make
common interactions
easier for users
with physical disabilities.
In the US alone,
this is a population
of over 75 million users.
Accessibility Menu simplifies
the following functions--
hardware shortcuts including
power off, lock screen,
take screenshot,
and volume control;
gestures like swipe
up and swipe down
for recent apps, notifications,
and quick settings.
It'll also allow you
to invoke the assistant
or go directly to Accessibility
Settings instantly.
Further, we designed it with
very large touch targets
located at the
bottom of the screen.
This facilitates reachability
for those with smaller hands
or limited reach.
It works in both portrait
and landscape mode.
Lastly, Accessibility
Menu is built on top
of our accessibility framework.
We added two new APIs for
screenshot and lock screen,
so developers can
start using it today.
So now, I'm going to
pass the baton over
to Patrick to talk a
little bit about vision.
PATRICK CLARY:
Cool, thanks, Brian.
All right, hello, everyone.
My name's Patrick Clary.
I'm a product manager on
Accessibility at Google,
and I'm very excited
today to announce,
for the very first
time here at I/O,
a new app coming to the
Play Store called Lookout.
So Lookout is a
new app for users
who are blind and low vision,
and it'll be useful for them
in certain situations where
they require help from others.
So for example,
one of these users
might be entering a new
space for the first time.
They might not know
if other people
are present in that space.
They might need assistance--
for example, finding a chair
or reading the office directory.
Another example is
when a user is cooking.
They might need assistance
reading a recipe
or locating different
ingredients.
So the goal of Lookout is to
leverage a user's smartphone
to make these physical spaces
and others more accessible
to these users who are blind
or have vision impairments.
You can think of Lookout
as a personal guide that
sees the world and speaks
items of importance
that it detects in
the environment.
So when a user downloads
Lookout and opens the app,
this is what they'll see.
They'll see a mode
selection where
they can pick between
four different modes,
and at launch, we'll support
Work and Play, Home, Scanning,
which is for scanning long
form text, and Experimental.
These allow users
to actually specify
the activity they
are partaking in
and fine-tunes Lookout to
provide more relevant results.
So after selecting
a mode, a user
will be presented with
a live view, which
we'll speak items of
importance as they're detected.
Next, I'd like to roll
just a short video that
profiles one of our testers,
who's an artist up in San
Francisco, and describes the
impact that an app like this
can have.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My first experience
with the Labyrinth
was this amazing
piece of canvas art
that we're being
allowed to walk on kind
of in this swirling
choreography.
I was so excited to
experience this new thing.
My name is Mia Scott.
I am a theater and
art instructor.
I was born visually impaired.
I kind of see like an
impressionist painting.
I'm often scootching around,
working with my supplies,
and they don't always end
up where I want them to be.
And I can't find the scissors.
[BEEPING OF THE APP]
- Scissors at 12 o'clock.
- Both as an artist and a
teacher, building a labyrinth
was the next step
for me, to invite
people to have a physical
experience with art
and not just observe it.
Very much in our
lives, we're invited
to watch or listen instead
of witnessing or doing.
[BEEPING OF THE APP]
- Lavender at 12 o'clock.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PATRICK CLARY: So that
gives you a little idea
of the type of experience
that Lookout can provide.
So when we were
building Lookout,
we focused on what we
called a passive experience,
and we imagined users using
it by wearing their Android
device in a lanyard like this
or perhaps in a shirt pocket.
Now, this is a big objective of
ours, this passive experience.
We don't want to force the
user to interrupt the activity
they're engaging with.
For example, if the
user is cooking,
they can remain engaged
in that activity
without having to
take out their device
and interact with the screen.
So while wearing
the phone, Lookout
provides these useful hints
about what the user is holding
in front of them, and
to facilitate this,
we've designed a set
of external controls.
So as you may have
noticed in the video,
a user can actually
knock on the device
to begin the recognition, this
live recognition that Lookout
provides.
And they can do other things
like cover the camera to pause
recognition or use
the fingerprint sensor
to change different modes.
So let me tell you a little
bit about how this works.
So first, Lookout will collect
live imagery of the scene
around the user,
and then we'll run
a series of machine
learning recognizers
to detect things like barcodes,
detect if people are present,
detect objects, and
read text in the scene.
The next thing we do is
score these items, first
based on a personalization
model and the mode
that the user has chosen.
This way, we only speak the
relevant and important items
to the user.
This is important
because, as you
can imagine, in
a standard scene,
there could be many
things we want to--
we can detect.
However, we only
want to tell the user
about the important
things based on what
we know about the context
that they're currently in.
It's important to note
that we do most of this
all on the device, so
that latency is low,
and you can actually
use this app completely
without an internet connection.
So that's Lookout,
an app for users
who are blind and
low vision that
harnesses the power
of machine learning
to provide relevant results
about physical spaces
around them.
It's coming to the Play Store
for users in the US on Pixel
devices very soon this summer.
And we'll also start rolling
out to trusted testers,
so if you'd like
to test this app,
go to google.com/accessibility
and sign up to be a trusted
tester.
You can come to our sandbox
to see a demo as well.
So next, I'll hand
it over to Maya,
who'll talk about what we're
doing in the cognitive space.
MAYA BEN-ARI:
Thank you, Patrick.
Hi, I'm Maya Ben-Ari,
and I'm a product manager
on Android framework.
A year ago, we launched
a service called Select
to Speak, target at user
with difficulties of reading.
Select to Speak allows
user to select and--
on the screen, and the
text will be read aloud.
Today, we're happy
to announce that we
added OCR capability to Select
to Speak in camera and picture.
This makes text even
more accessible.
User can simply select
text using the camera
or in the picture, and the text
will be highlighted and read
aloud.
Now, I want to show
you a brief demo.
For that, I'm actually
going to go off the stage.
I'm going to open my camera.
Can my camera be shown?
Here you go.
So this is the live camera view,
and this is the regular camera.
And I have here the
Accessibility button.
I have here the Accessibility
button here in the corner.
I'm going to turn it on.
And next, I'm going
to select the text.
CELL PHONE VOICE:
Select to Speak with OCR
is available in
Android P Beta today.
Please try it out.
MAYA BEN-ARI: Thank you.
Now, back to the stage,
and where's my clicker?
Here you go, clicker.
So it's available in
Android P Beta today.
It's going to come soon
to the general beta.
We'd love to have your feedback.
Now, I'm going to talk a
bit about Android framework,
and our goal in the Android
Accessibility framework
is to help get rid
of the assumptions
that device are built on.
For example, not all users can
interact with the touch screen
or with the standard UI
or even hear the sounds
that the device is producing.
Now, we're supporting
this goal in two ways.
The first one is
we're developing
APIs for apps and services
to make it easier to support
wide range of audience.
And second, we are implementing
accessibility features
into the framework.
Now, I will talk about
three new API addition
to enable developers to make
their app more accessible,
and the first one
is add a pane title.
So first, let me start
with, what is a pane?
A pane is a section of the
window that these visually
distinct for user with--
which is visually
distinct for user,
and change it like
a window changes.
An example of the
pane, you can see here
in the Quick Setting and
the notification shade.
Prior to Android P,
Accessibility Services
could not easily determined
when panes on the screen
had been updated.
In Android P, we added an
attribute called Accessibility
Pane Title.
Now, Accessibility
Services are automatically
notified to changes
to the pane so user
get more granular
information about what
has changed with minimal
input from app developer.
So please do add a
title to your pane.
The second API is called
an Accessibility Heading.
This is an attribute
so developer
can mark whether something is
a heading inside their app,
and this is intended for
apps with text heavy views.
This will allow TalkBack to a
user who cannot see the screen
to navigate more efficiently
between different heading
inside their app without force
listening to the whole text.
And the last API is
we add the ability--
we basically-- the last API is
for setting what is focusable,
and that API is
designed to control
the grouping of the content.
For example, let's say that
you have sports scores,
and you want to ensure that
the number goes with the team
instead of TalkBack reading
all the teams and then all
the numbers, which can be very
confusing for the users who
cannot see the screen.
Now, you can use
Screen Reader Focusable
to improve how screen
readers group the content.
And by the way, we're also
updating our documentation
for Accessibility
Focus and Grouping,
so please check it out,
the Accessibility Section
in developer.android.com.
Now, I'm going to talk about
three new additional features
coming to the Android framework.
The first one is
Adjust Vibration.
This is a new setting for
users with dexterity issues
to adjust the ringer
notification vibration and also
the touch sensitivity.
The second setting is
called Remove Animation,
as some users find
animation distracting,
so we basically just added a
new setting to turn those off.
And the last feature is, a year
ago, we launched the Volume Key
Accessibility Shortcut.
So basically, to toggle on and
off Accessibility Services,
you need to long press, for
three seconds, the volume keys.
Now, we did two changes to
that one based on the feedback.
The first one, we
added new setting
that you can toggle
on and off, which
is Color Correction
and Coloring Version.
And the second one is
we reduced the time
to activate from three
seconds to one second
after the initial activation.
In the next section,
I'm going to talk
about testing for accessibility
and its importance
for everything that
we build into the OS.
We see the power of the
Accessibility Services
in the app ecosystem, and
we want that ecosystem to be
as accessible as possible.
Now, there are multiple ways to
test including manual testing
and automated testing.
In general, we found
the combination of both
could provide you a better
coverage for your app.
Next, I'm going to cover
different testing tools
and how those can be integrated
to cover accessibility--
to discover
accessibility issues.
First, let me talk a little
bit about manual testing.
This is the most reliable
way to understand
how your products are
used by different users
with disabilities.
What you need there is you
need to turn on TalkBack
or Switch Access with
your app because you
want to be in the
shoes of the user
to feel how it is to run
an Accessibility Service.
However, we are aware that
manual testing takes time,
and you cannot test for
every change that you make
into the app, and for
that, we also provide--
there is also automated testing.
We develop Android
Accessibility Testing Framework,
also shortly called
ATF, to quickly identify
common accessibility issues
early in the development cycle.
ATF is an open source
library, which we already
integrated into Espresso and
Roboelectric Testing Framework
so you can leverage your
existing test to identify
accessibility issues.
ATF 3.0 is now
available on GitHub.
Next, we have two
automated tools
that integrate Accessibility
Testing Framework--
Play Pre-Launch Report
and Accessibility Scanner.
In Play Pre-Launch Report,
we're making it even easier
to get accessibility
tests resolved
by integrating those directly
into the developer console.
Now, first, what is
Play Pre-Launch Report?
This is an automated
testing solution,
which calls apps on
multiple physical devices
and detects issues the developer
can fix before reaching
their end users,
including recognizing
crashes and performance issues.
The tool runs automatically
on all APK published
to the alpha and beta channel.
Now, Play Pre-Launch--
Play Pre-Launch Report also
include accessibility tests.
This is yet another
example how we
integrate our core
accessibility testing library.
As Play Pre-Launch Report calls
your app, as in this example--
this is a cooking app.
In each step, it will launch
accessibility tests including
contrast ratio, touch target
size, missing labels, and so
on.
And the test result will
be automatically integrated
into the test report.
This will provide the developer
an opportunity to fix those--
to fix those before their
app launches and make
their app more accessible.
Lastly, I'll mention
Accessibility Scanner,
which is an app that suggests
accessibility improvement
for Android apps utilizing
Accessibility Testing
Framework.
And we're very happy
that up until today,
Accessibility Scanner
discovered more than three
and a half million opportunities
for improving accessibility
in apps--
for improving
accessibility apps.
So big shout out for
Accessibility Scanner.
A new version of
Accessibility Scanner
is available today with
additional accessibility
checks, such as Traversal
Order for Screenwriter,
an inferent element
for accessibility.
We also improve the UI
for contrast suggestion.
And finally, we also are
allowing changes for threshold
for contrast ratio
and touch target size.
So to download
Accessibility Scanner,
please go to
g.co/accessibilityscanner.
To sum up this section, we
talked about manual testing,
and we showed a number of
tools to help automate testing.
But the most successful projects
incorporate both manual testing
and automated
testing, so please,
do try out the
different tools and do
develop a testing strategy for
accessibility for your app.
Now, another vital
piece of the puzzle
is to understand
the user experience
and your user needs,
and with that said,
I will hand it off to Melissa
to talk about user research.
MELISSA BARNHART:
Thank you, Maya.
My name's Melissa Barnhart,
and I'm a user experience
researcher on Android.
So now that we've
gotten a sneak peek
at the accessibility features
and services coming in Android
P, I'd like to
talk about the role
of user research and the
design and development process.
But first, what exactly
is user research?
User research focuses on
understanding user behaviors,
needs, and motivations.
It is the process of
understanding the impact
of design on an audience.
So as technologists, we may
think we know what's best
for our users, but
oftentimes, we don't.
The user is truly the
expert in their experiences.
By seeking to understand
user behaviors, needs,
and motivations, we start
to challenge our assumptions
and reshape our perspectives.
Why do it?
Why do we do user research?
You may have heard the stat that
nine out of 10 startups fail,
but you may not know that the
number one reason for failure
is lack of a market
need for a product.
So in those situations, people
design and develop products,
then look for an
audience who might
be interested in using them.
User research advocates
for the opposite.
By putting users first,
you can validate your ideas
and inform your
product's direction.
Hopefully, you're thinking,
great, but when do I get
started?
And the short answer is now.
User research involves
a set of practices
that runs along your existing
product development cycle,
helping you make
decisions at each stage.
So methods like field
studies, interviews,
or competitive
analysis can help you
explore a specific
area of technology
and uncover opportunity areas.
Once you've decided
what you want to build,
and you have a
prototype, methods
like cognitive walkthroughs,
usability tests,
or participatory
design exercises
can help you make
important design decisions.
And once your product
is out in the market,
methods like log analysis,
diary studies, or surveys
can help you evaluate
its performance.
And if you don't have a lot of
time or experience, that's OK.
Just take a few hours
and talk to a few users.
Jacob Nielsen of the
Nielsen Norman Group
found that the best results come
from small affordable studies
with no more than five users.
So now, I'd like to
show you how Android
uses user research to improve
our accessibility offerings.
Let's take the example of
TalkBack vibration feedback.
TalkBack, the Google
screen reader,
uses vibration
feedback by default.
We knew that some
people turned this off,
and we wanted to know why.
Why do some people turn it
off while others leave it on?
Are there situations
where vibration
is more or less useful, and
does the pattern or intensity
of the vibration
make a difference?
Good research starts with
good research questions.
Because we were
interested in perceptions
of vibration feedback, we
started with user interviews.
We asked screen reader
users questions like,
do you use vibration feedback?
Why or why not?
Have you ever turned it off?
When did you turn it off?
And how would you describe
the intensity of vibration
on your phone?
Is it too high, too
low, or just right?
After getting a sense of
the participants' needs,
we prompted them to
compare vibration feedback
across a range of
Android phones.
So these tasks added a usability
component to our study.
In this research, we
validated a real need
for vibration feedback.
We learned that
vibration provides
valuable navigational
information
to visually impaired
users, especially
in noisy environments
when they may not
be able to hear spoken
feedback on their device.
We also learned that the more
distinct the vibration pattern,
the more useful.
Finally, we learned that
users wanted the ability
to adjust vibration
intensity according
to their personal preferences.
So in Android P, we're
giving up greater control
to the user over
vibration feedback.
Anyone will be able to go to
their Accessibility Settings
and increase, decrease,
or disable vibration,
and this is just the beginning.
We will continue to make
improvements in this area
as we further research.
So now, we're going to
hand it over to Victor
for some final
announcements and resources
to help you going forward.
VICTOR TSARAN: Thanks,
Melissa, for highlighting
the importance of
use of research
in the product
decisions we make--
super important, as
you have seen already.
Well, next, we couldn't just
let you go without a few more
announcements, could we?
First, I'd like to announce
that Voice Access--
the accessibility service that
helps someone with dexterity
issues to use their
Android phone completely
through their voice just
simply issuing voice commands.
Voice Access is
graduating from beta.
After months of user research,
development iterations,
we're finally ready to
launch it and give it to you.
Coming soon, this summer,
with new UI enhancements,
better Assistant integration--
and by Assistant,
I mean Google Assistant,
just to be sure--
coming with Google
Assistant UI, and more
improved interaction overall.
So lookout for Voice Access.
The next thing I'd like
to let you know about
is that we decided
to package a lot
of our accessibility
services that you commonly
find built into
an Android device
into a single package we call
Android Accessibility Suite.
Some of the services include
TalkBack screen reader
for people who are blind
and vision impaired;
Switch Access, a
software that allows
people with physical impairments
to use their device with just
a single button or
a single switch;
Select to Speak that Maya
just demoed a few minutes ago;
and Accessibility Menu that
Brian also showcased earlier;
and more to come.
We hope that with a new
Android Accessibility Suite,
other accessibility
services, not just TalkBack,
will be more discoverable
in the Play Store,
as well as this will
become a platform
for new future accessibility
services we will be developing.
But enough about us.
I think its time to talk
about you a little bit.
I think you deserve it, guys.
You build a lot of
the cool stuff, too.
Last evening, we announced
Google Play Awards,
and I just would like
to give a shout out
to a few amazing developers
that have been working
on stuff or apps to make our
ecosystem better and more
accessible.
First, our winner is Be My Eyes.
Be My Eyes is a
cross-platform solution
that connects
people who need help
with people who are willing
or excited to give that help.
The way this service works
is that someone who is blind
or who needs help requests
it by declaring themselves
as a person who needs help, and
then people on the other end
can sign up as volunteers.
And when such help request
comes, they get notification.
Then they pick up
the video link,
and then they can help
somebody in real time.
So Be My Eyes--
check it out on the Play Store.
The next one I'd like to
mention is the OpenSesame.
Now, OpenSesame is already
known to some people who
have been with us during
various Google I/O events
and otherwise.
The coolness of OpenSesame
accessibility solution
is that it allows people
to control their Android
device by just looking at it.
It's amazing.
So check out OpenSesame, and
the link is on the screen.
The last but not least, I'd like
to mention, we really, really,
really care about Game
because, while it's
an important aspect
of computing to be
productive and independent, it's
just as important to have fun.
And so one of our
yesterday winners
is a company from New Zealand
called Audio Game Hub,
and what they've created
is an experience for anyone
to be able to play audio
games with their eyes closed.
So you only rely on
your ears and then
you play all kind
of funky games.
I'm not going to
name those games.
I hope you'll go
to the Play Store
and check them out for yourself.
And I'd like to leave
you with a few resources.
We already mentioned
Accessibility Scanner.
Please download it.
Test with Accessibility Scanner.
The website where you can find
all of the best accessibility
practices for
Android development,
g.co/androidaccessibility,
and of course, user research.
And last but not
least, of course, we
have lots of sessions for you to
explore here at the Google I/O.
It's a great opportunity
just for you to meet us,
for us to meet you, so
that we can together
create a more friendly and
more accessible and inclusive
ecosystem.
Thank you for coming here today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]